Können Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamen bestabieren, Frau Schauer?
SCH, Anton, Uwe Udo, Ibn-Irwih, und Erwin Richard.
Okay, danke. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 32 Jahre alt.
23, ja. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
25.04.1992.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,63 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zurzeit?
Also ungefähr 65 kg.
Okay, danke für die Information, Frau Schauer.
Was für Sie heute bei uns? Was für Beschwerden haben Sie im Moment?
Also Herr Doktor, ich habe seit 4 Wochen ungefähr so komische Bauchschmerzen.
Die gehen nicht weg, das wird immer mehr, mehr, weniger.
Aber es ist irgendwie komisch.
Könnten Sie mir sagen, wo die Schmerzen am stärksten sind?
Hier oben, in der Magenbereich.
Manchmal geht es in die Mitte von Bapu, wo der Narbel ist.
Und es ist ein bisschen defus.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie seit 4 Wochen Bauchschmerzen haben.
War der beginnt, prösti oder langsam?
Das hat in den ersten ein paar Tagen, da habe ich mir nichts dabei gedacht.
Ich dachte, das ist einfach ein Mageninfekt, das geht wieder vorbei.
Das war auch gut, aber dann ist es wieder schlimmer geworden.
Sind die Schmerzen immer da oder gehen Sie manchmal wieder weg?
Also die kommen und gehen, aber seit einer Woche sind sie immer da.
Seit einer Woche?
Ja.
Wie würden Sie diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind Sie erdubend, stehend, brennend?
Nein, ich würde sagen, erdubend.
Und manchmal habe ich schon eine leichte Übelkeit.
Seit wann haben Sie Übelkeit?
Seit 2 Wochen ungefähr.
Haben Sie sie schon einmal erbrochen?
Nein, habe ich jetzt nicht, aber die Übelkeit ist sehr unterschiedlich.
Man ist sehr stark, man ist sehr weniger.
Neben dieser Übelkeit haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden.
Bauchschmerzen, Übelkeit.
Nein, das war es eigentlich. Manchmal das Gefühl, dass ich ein bisschen gebläht wirke.
Aber auch ein bisschen dicker ist.
Und dadurch habe ich auch manchmal etwas weniger Appetit.
Gibt es etwas, was das Schmerz, z.B. Versterk oder Linder?
Wenn ich ein bisschen Schmerztabletten nehme, dann wird es weniger.
Ich habe jetzt Paracetamol genommen, die letzten Tage, dann ist es etwas besser geworden.
Aber es kommt dann wieder, sobald die Wirkung nachlässt, kommen die Beschwerden wieder.
Und ich merke, wenn ich etwas esse, dass es nach dem Essen während des Schmerzes auch etwas stärker.
Okay.
Wie starten die Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzspalle von 1 bis 10?
1 steht für sehr leicht der Schmerz, 10 steht für unerträglich der Schmerz.
Ja, sehr unterschiedlich. Anfänglich war es vielleicht so 1, 2, jetzt würde ich sagen so bei 4, 5.
Sie haben gesagt, dass die Medikamente eingehörten.
Sind Sie deswegen beim anderen Ast gewesen?
Nein, bisher noch nicht.
Haben Sie schon mal NGB-Schwerden gehabt?
Nein.
Hatten Sie einen Unfall?
Nein, nein, unfallertig nicht.
Okay.
Verspülen Sie Herzrasen oder Atemproblem?
Mir nicht auch gefallen, nein, habe ich jetzt nicht.
Fühlen Sie Sie in der letzten Zeit Fibrik oder haben Sie Fieber?
Fieber nicht, aber so ein bisschen schwach, so ein bisschen kraftlos.
Okay.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Ungewollte?
Nein, also das Gewicht bleibt eigentlich immer gleich.
Aber Sie haben Appetit, in Appetit haben Sie?
Ja, in den letzten Tagen habe ich weniger Appetit, aber abgenommen habe ich jetzt noch nicht.
Okay, gut.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasser lassen oder mit dem Stuhl?
Nein, bisher nicht, eigentlich ganz normal.
Können Sie gut schlafen?
Schlafen geht ja.
Okay, Frau Schauer, ich möchte einige Fragen zu Ihrer Kraftengeschichte stellen.
Leiden Sie unter kranker Krankheiten?
Nein, bisher ist nichts bekannt, nein, eigentlich bin ich bisher ganz gesund.
Sind Sie regelmäßig bei Ihrem Hausarzt?
Nur wenn ich mal krank bin, aber ansonsten nicht, nein.
Also ich habe mir bisher nichts gehabt.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikament oder bei Bedarf?
Ich nehme nur die Pille und sonst habe ich keine Medikamente.
Seit wann nehmen Sie diese Pille?
Ja gut, seitdem ich 16 Jahre bin, also das sind jetzt auch 16 Jahre.
Ansonsten nehmen Sie keine Medikamente?
Nein, keine regelmäßigen Medikamente, nein.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Nein, habe ich.
Ich sehe aber alles ganz in Ordnung.
Gut.
Sind bei Ihnen irgendwelche Allergien oder Unverzwechlichkeiten bekannt?
Also ich habe Allergien gegen Polen.
Wie auserst sich diese Allergien?
Bitte.
Wie auserst sich diese Polenallergien?
Ja, wenn die Polenzeit kommt, dann läuft mir die Nase, ich habe so einen Yukreiz in den Augen
und ich kriege dann so ein bisschen Kratznehmhals, das sind so die typischen Symptome halt.
Was wollte ich mal sagen?
Haben Sie keine Unverzwechlichkeiten gegen einen Lungsmittel?
Ja, so, ich habe so eine leichte Laktoseintoleranz.
Sind Sie vollständig gegen Corona und Kinderkrankheiten?
Ja, ich habe es vor kurzem deswegen noch mal beim Hausarzt, also da war jetzt bisher kein Problem.
Die Impfungen müssten eigentlich komplett sein.
Okay, waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Verreist? Nein, nein, war ich nicht.
Zwei Mal sind Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ja, ich gehe zweimal die Woche auf uns im Fitnessstudio, mache ein bisschen Fitness und Kardiosport
und manchmal mache ich auch mal ein bisschen Pilates.
Gut. Frau Schau, ich möchte noch etwas wissen über Ihre Lebensgewohnheiten.
Rauchen Sie?
Ab und zu malen, nicht immer, aber manchmal.
Wenn man eine Feier ist oder wenn man mit Freunden mal zusammenkommt, aber nicht regelmäßig.
Seit wann rauchen Sie?
Ungefähr.
Ach, immer wieder mal, so, vielleicht seit zehn Jahren.
Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Nein, Alkohol trinke ich nicht.
Und routinemäßig muss man fragen, ob Sie Kontakt mit Drogen haben.
Mit Drogen? Nein, nein.
Sind bei Ihren Eltern, ich möchte über Ihre Familien am Nese etwas fragen,
sind bei Ihren Eltern chronische Erkrankungen bekannt?
Zum Beispiel Zuckerkrankungen, Krebskrankungen?
Krebserkrankungen sind glücklicherweise bisher nicht bekannt, aber mein Vater hat einen hohen Blutdruck
und dagegen nimmt auch Medikamente ein.
Ich glaube, er hat auch etwas an seinen Herz gefäst.
Der hat letztes Jahr mal einen Herzkatheter gehabt und nimmt dann dagegen auch Medikamente,
aber ich weiß nicht, was es ist.
Und meine Mutter, die hat an dich jetzt keine schwerwiegende Krankungen.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe noch einen Bruder, habe ich noch.
Ist er gesund?
Ja, er ist jünger als ich, er ist zwei Jahre jünger als ich und er ist sportlich,
ist gesund, also da wüsste ich jetzt nichts, was er an Erkrankungen hätte.
Was machen Sie bei der Frau Schauer?
Ich bin im Kontrolling tätig in einer großen Firma.
Sind Sie bei der Arbeit Stress ausgesetzt?
Ja, aber ich kann mich nicht beklagen, das ist halt mehr und mal weniger, aber es geht.
Also ich bin meistens im Büro, so viel Stress ist es jetzt nicht.
Okay, das freut mich.
Wie ist Ihre Familie stand? Sind Sie teils heiratet?
Nein, ich lebe mit meinem Freund, sonst sind längere zusammen, aber wir sind noch nicht feier.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, wir sind ja auch nicht.
Okay, kurz zu Ihren aktuellen Bescheiden, Frau Schauer, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit etwas Ungewöhnliches gegessen, vielleicht?
Nein, ich fährt mir nichts ein, eigentlich das, was ich bisher immer esse, da war jetzt nichts Ungewöhnliches dabei.
Okay, ich habe keine Fragen mehr, Frau Schauer.
Haben wir alles besprochen oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, ich werde Ihnen sehr dankbar, wenn Sie mal herausfinden, was das jetzt ist,
dass Sie das so langsam macht, dass Sie mir sorgen und deswegen bin ich gekommen.
Es ist verständlich, dass Ihre Symptome Ihren Sorgen bereiten, aber es war gut, dass Sie es uns gekommen sind.
Ich werde Sie jetzt noch Köpfe untersuchen, dann nehmen wir noch Bulletab, machen eine Ultraschall Ihres Bauches,
dann besprechen wir, was das Problem sein könnte oder die Befunde, dann sehen wir, wie es weitergeht.
Ja, super, vielen Dank, das hört sich schon mal ganz gut an, damit ich froh, dass ich jetzt doch gekommen bin.
Okay, lassen Sie uns untersuchen, Herr Gebner, Sie haben eine Frage.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ja bitte.
Frau Schauer, haben Sie in der letzten Woche eine blasse Haut in der Märkte?
Blasse Haut, nein.
Haben Sie Lymphknoten an Ihre fälschliche Körperregionen bemerkt?
Nein, das mache ich regelmäßig, wenn ich dusche, dass sie mich so ein bisschen abtaste,
aber so vergrößerte Lymphknoten oder Aufwendigkeiten habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Okay, danke.
Was ist denn das für eine Frage?
Haben Sie Sodbrennen oder Stoffaus?
Sodbrennen habe ich jetzt nicht, aber wie gesagt, eine leichte Übelkeit.
Okay, danke.
Eine Frage.
Schön.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Ihre Stuhlgangfarbe veränderungen?
Stuhlgangfarbe.
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen, also der Stuhlgang ist normal und die Farbe war eigentlich auch bisher, wie immer.
Okay.
Haben Sie unregenmäßige Menstruasiklus?
Da habe ich bisher keine Brüde getrunken, ist immer regelmäßig.
Das Frage.
Wie geht es in der Schwere der Erörfamilie?
Wüsste ich jetzt nicht, nein, ich bin jetzt nicht aufgefallen.
Woher kommen Sie?
Hier aus Mannheim.
Sie haben gesagt, nachdem es sich ihre Schmerzen verstärken.
Das ist eigentlich egal, egal, was ich esse, das heißt, sobald ich irgendwas im Magen habe, wird die Überkeit etwas schlechter.
Vielleicht oder andere?
Egal, das ist egal.
Haben Sie Schuldungstürm?
Nein.
Haben Sie Auslöse bemacht?
Nein, wie gesagt, nach dem Essen wird es schlimmer, aber ansonsten gibt es keinen richtigen Auslöser, wo ich sagen kann.
Wachen Sie nachts auch vor Schmerzen?
Ein paar Mal vor Schmerzen nicht, aber da war mir auch bis Lübel gemacht worden, aber ich konnte dann wieder einschlafen.
Ich denke, alle Fragen gestärken.
Könnten wir als erstes die Schiebri anfangen?
Ich sage mal, die Ergebnisse von den Laborwerten, unauffälliges Blutbild.
Die Leberwerte sind nur ganz leicht erhöht, GPT, Gamma, GT, GOT, leicht erhöht.
Bilirubin ist unverändert und sonst in dem normalen Labor keine Aufwärtigkeiten, kein CRP.
Urin, Urin status?
Urin ist unauffällig.
Und im Ultraschwald Abtomen sieht man Gallenblasensteile, aber die Gallenblasenwand ist unauffällig.
Man sieht einen weisen Fleck, einen runden kreisförmigen weisen Fleck in der Leber, circa 3 cm.
Im Status gefragt, oder?
Ja, im Status ist gefragt, er war unauffällig.
Partitis AB?
Das hat sie jetzt nicht, der Partitis AB hat sie nicht gehabt, nein.
Noch keine Impfung.
Okay, das war es erstmal.
Darf ich anfangen?
Natürlich.
Schon gut, Herr Oberarst, gerade habe ich eine neue Patientin, die Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Schön, dass Sie da sind.
Ich habe es nicht gut verstanden.
Ich habe nur gut amt gesagt, hallo.
Okay, es handelt sich um Frau Manuela Schauer, sie ist 32 Jahre alt, 1,63 m groß, wiegt 65 kg.
Er stellte sie heute bei uns.
Wie stellte sie sich?
Sie stellte sie heute bei uns, seit 4 Wochen, bestehenden epigastischen Schmerzen vor.
Die Schmerzen seien langsam aufgetreten und hätten sie im Laufe derzeit verschlimmert.
Seit einer Woche sind die Schmerzen immer da.
Sie halten sie an.
Begleitend klackte sie über die Überleitung seit 2 Wochen, jedoch ohne Erbrechen.
Erwehren ist das, die Schmerzen nachdemessen, das sie schmerzen nachdemessen, verschlimmert wurden.
Sie beschreibt die Schmerzen als Stumpf und bewertet die Schmerzintensität manchmal 1-2 von 10, manchmal 4-5 von 10.
Sie haben die Schmerzen im Nabelbereich.
Sie haben die Schmerzen im Unbillikal.
Sie haben bisher keine Älge beschwerden gehabt, keinen Unfall und keinen Arzt aufgesucht.
Deswegen.
Die vegetative Anamnese war unaufwählig bis auf Inappetanz.
Keine Vorerkrankungen sind bei der Patientin bekannt.
Sie nehmen seit ihren 16 Jahren Lebensjahr Pille.
Ansonsten nimmt sie keine Medikamente ein.
Sie wurde bisher noch nie operiert.
Eine Polyan allergie ist bei ihr bekannt, die sich mit Renekonjunktivitis und Pruritus aushält.
Eine leichte Laktoseintoleranz ist bei ihr bekannt.
Ihr im Status sei vollständig.
Eine Reise an einem Nese liegt nicht vor.
Sie treiben regelmäßig 2-mal wöchentlich Sport.
Sie raut seit 10 Jahren sehr selten,
und haben keine Alkohol, Drogen und Konsum.
Die ökologischen Anamnese sind unaufwählig.
Sie haben eine gesunde Bruder.
Der Beruf ist als Kontrolleur tätig.
Sie lebt mit ihrem Freund und hat keine Kinder.
Was macht der Patientin?
Aufgrund der Symptomatik denke ich an eine Ulkustventurkillerie.
Sie denken an einen Magenproblem?
Als differenzialen Diagnosen kommen eine Polylithiasis.
Sie denken an die kleinen?
Eine Corona-Herz-Krankheit.
Sie haben schon sehr weit geholt.
Sie haben keine Kardiane an einem Nese.
Sie haben nicht gefragt.
Sie denken, es könnte ein anderes Gefäßproblem sein.
Sie denken an eine Gastritis.
Sie denken, es könnte noch sein.
Was gibt es noch in diesem Bereich?
Sie haben keine Diagnose.
Sie haben keine Dyspnyl.
Sie können Kollegen helfen.
Sie denken, es könnte noch sein.